it is so exciting when we have
people in the live we've got a
phenomenal group of people out in the
lobby here today of ramsey solutions and
across the uh across the aisle here is
donna who is standing on the debt
free stage she's here for a debt-free
scream
donna welcome how are you i'm great how
are you
i am living the dream and it looks like
you are too
so good to have you with us where are
you from um pensacola florida
i've been there for um two years
originally from oklahoma
okay great and how much debt did you pay
off
120 000 total in 16 months
whoa in 16 months
and range of income during that time uh
joe and i started with
a hundred for base pay total and then
with overtime uh it was got up to 160
and now it's down to 40. okay and
down to 40. okay and i'm i'm going to do
some
quick math here joe yes is not here
joe's not here where is joe chose with
jesus
oh my gosh and so you guys did this
journey today we did this together we
got out
of debt together yeah wow unbelievable
what happened
um he was scuba diving his favorite
thing to do
and uh they don't really know what
happened um
our friends that are in medicine that
know him and know
what he was experiencing said they think
he had a blood clot in his leg that
probably went to his lungs
but the autopsy doesn't show anything
definitive for that wow
well i'm so so sorry for your 49.
49 years of age how long ago did this
happen
three months oh my goodness and so you
did the debt free journey together so
we did you get debt free yes and what's
the the timeline between
you guys get debt free and then he
passes away well our goal was
to get the end of the debt paid off
before the cruise
oh which we have cruise shirts i
see that yes that's right daughter
harmony had these made up she and her
husband and joe and i were going on the
cruise
so we got it paid off before the cruise
yeah and then my youngest son
his wedding got postponed because of
covid
and his wedding was the end of
june and one week exactly before the
wedding was when joe passed
my goodness and my debt free screen was
supposed to be two days after the
wedding and we moved it to today
oh my goodness so
and there's a hurricane on my house i
know as soon as you soon as you said
pensacola i saw pictures of it in the
news yesterday
this the downtown pensacola was under
water the streets were flooded
bless your heart well i'm not going to
ask you how you're doing because this
has got to be
one of the most confusing emotional
times because you and joe go through
this together yes
an unbelievable journey and and then all
of a sudden it hits and i've just got to
ask i mean you're three months into this
i'm just trying to figure out what life
is like on the other side of this
how much does it mean to you to be
debt-free
it's absolutely amazing um
because i would um
like we bought a house i would be
terrified if i
was having to um meet all the
obligations
of what people normally have to deal
with on forty thousand dollars a year
did you pay the house off as well
we did oh my gosh oh
that's incredible baby stuff seven
and so you you're dealing with this pain
and and yet you've got some peace you do
have true financial peace
what do you do for a living we both work
for the u.s postal service
as mail handlers working during the
night okay wow
and so uh what do you say to people
uh about this journey that you all went
through
uh because you did this together and uh
i'm just curious well
let's go back okay i'm trying to process
what you're dealing with and i can't
because it's unbelievable your strength
is is just unbelievable so inspired by
you
what what what what caused you and joe
to look at each other and go hey we got
to get out of debt
so when we got engaged he knew that i
didn't have any debt and he said well
i've got 70 000 in debt
and so i said okay you know you have to
get out of debt he's like yeah i know
did you did you say i'd give you a
conditional yes or did you say yes then
we got to do it
i said i will be your cheerleader while
you get out of that debt interesting so
you didn't say yes
i no i said yes to getting married okay
all right i didn't know if you said i'll
i'll say yes once you do this but you
went ahead did it and so he said yes
ma'am
yes he says i have no idea how to do
that okay
and i didn't believe him so ladies
listen to your husbands if they say they
need your input
because i really didn't think i thought
he was just being sweet yeah he was
being honest he had no clue
and i said well you got to pay off that
that lowest
card first and he did and after he got
married came back from the honeymoon i
get a bill in the mail a month later and
he had filled it up again
i said what happened he goes i told you
i don't know how to do this i need your
help i went oh he really meant it yeah
right
he really needs my help so i started
researching and that's when i found dave
ramsey's podcast
and then i started watching the youtube
show when i woke up
because that's what time i woke up in
the afternoon to go to work and i'd
watch it live
and then i would go to work and then
work eight hours and then i'd work
overtime and listen to the podcast that
i just watched that day
during my overtime is my motivation to
not go home to stay there yeah
wow all right so what would you say to
people
if you if you could have everybody in
the world who's struggling with debt and
they're looking at this journey they're
going can i actually get through the
baby steps what would you say the key is
to get where you are now
i would say for someone that's our age
it was second marriages for us
and it's really really important to
as dave says put all the money on the
table put all income and all the debt on
the table and fight it together
because i had looked at we were both
doing the every dollar budget separately
and on his budget it showed in the debt
category he was making minimum payments
of 2 300
a month i said you realize what life
would be if you didn't have
those 2 300 of debt payments if you
could just do whatever you wanted for
that
and he goes well i've always just worked
enough over time
to make it happen i said but you're not
getting anywhere
and so by us combining our finances
it wasn't just me cheerleading for him
um
i was i had skin in the game now yeah
you did yeah
and so nobody thinks on the outside of
this debt-free journey that tragedy is
somewhere on the other side yet we know
it's all we know it's possible
but we don't sit around thinking about
that but here you are debt free
and still healing after the tragic loss
of your partner
who walked through this journey with you
why is this
journey so important given the fact that
you have faced
the unexpected well because you don't
know what the future is going to hold
there's no way you'd want to hang on to
debt yeah you don't know what could
happen in your life
and it's not just the death of a spouse
it could be all sorts of things that
could happen and
you can't it's really really hard to
handle it if you
have that over your shoulders um
uh my daughter and her husband were of
incredible resource for me once before
in my life and i lived with them for a
year
so when this happened they said oh
please come live with us again
and i said you know last time i needed
to be with you financially but mentally
i was okay
this time i don't need to be with you
because of finances but emotionally is
where i need
help yeah you know so it's a different
situation here yeah
wow and in the lobby uh we can see
harmony and her husband malachi
that's my that's two of my kids oh both
i'm sorry oh i missed i misunderstood so
the two kids i
i apologize they punch each other you'll
know they're not married i get it
so we've got harmony and malachi two of
the kids and i know you're so proud of
your mom
uh and your dad and i know you all are
hurting as well so i'm gonna tell you
something on behalf of uh
everybody here we're hurting for you but
we're so excited
that you've got peace so here it is
folks donna
and joe watching from above donna and
joe
paid off 120 000 in
16 months including the house including
the house
donna take it away let's hear
a debt-free scream for you and joe
joe we did this together three two
one we're dead
holy moly my goodness
that is so powerful